la dépression c'est quoi en vrai la
dépression c'est un trouble qui touche
notre santé mentale et c'est loin d'être
rare c'est même assez courant puisque
dans le monde l'OMS estime que la
dépression touche un adulte sur 20 et en
France il y a une étude qui a conclu que
entre 2020 et 2021 12,5 % des adultes
ont connu un épisode dépressif et tout
ça ça a augmenté de 36 % par rapport aux
années précédentes attention là on parle
bien de dépression on parle pas d'un
coup de blouse ou d'une déprime
passagère la dépression c'est quelque
chose qui s'installe durablement plus ou
moins longtemps et qui modifie
profondément notre humeur au sens
psychiatrique du terme c'est-à-dire en
gros nos émotions et notre façon de les
gérer c'est une vraie souffrance
psychologique avec des conséquences sur
tous les aspects de la vie personnelles
professionnell et social vu que nos
relations avec les autres sont compliqué
voire complètement impossible pour être
très clair la dépression c'est une
maladie donc c'est pas une histoire de
courage ou de volonté on en a déjà parlé
mais ça fait pas de mal de le rappeler